you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now much
worse there but we are getting rain even
as we speak riding right through town up
in the far Northwest the palm trees blow
on rain in the Northwest and not a whole
lot of people using the park the latest
radar pictures are showing that we do
have rain marching right through the
valley and yes some lightning near the
215 the only advisories the wind
advisory the winter storm warning for
the higher elevations upwards of a foot
of snow and remember the Lee Canyon Ski
area is shut down now 61 at Reed
International but Gusty winds and rain
in the Northwest and the Southwest we've
already seen upwards of a tenth of an
inch of rain just in the last half hour
in parts of the Southwest around
Mountains Edge here at 58 Seven Hills at
59. we're going to be watching this but
it does look like it's racing through
fairly quickly maybe another couple of
hours of stuff like this 41 right now
for Tonopah a lot more snow in Reno snow
in Lincoln County and some very
difficult driving up there meantime we
may make it to 62 but I got a feeling
that 61 is probably going to be it for
the afternoon or daytime high for today
so the future cast shows that we're
going to continue to see the rain here
for the next half hour then quickly
moving through so that by two o'clock
maybe some areas of intense rain but
moving very rapidly so by three o'clock
we may be just about done and that's the
big picture here showing that by the end
of the day this storm system should be
clearing out we can check in on your
family and friends Across the Nation
snow showers that started the day in
Wyoming have kind of Fallen apart and
that goes for Denver as well but the
system we've got right now is headed
that way so here's your most accurate
eight day forecast windy with showers
today the sunshine returns tomorrow we
get a break for a day or so but Friday
the next round brings clouds with
chances for rain Saturday Sunday and
possibly Martin Luther King Jr day on
Monday Heather
what they do here